[Music]
the history of afghanistan from
alexander the great delau
is
one superpower or another coming in
dominating for a certain amount of time
and then departing
as they say the graveyard empires
the intelligence community had at least
one probable scenario
where the government would fall within
weeks
i don't think that we should be
surprised
uh you know that it fell quicker than
that
i should have seen this
[Music]
monumental decision about america's
longest 20 years
when you move the chess piece on the
board somebody else moves into that
position who is
calling it a red line
the stunning collapse of afghanistan
plays out in real time
we're ending america's longest war
[Applause]
[Applause]
years they've been trying to do this and
today the united states signed a deal
with the taliban
so that we can hopefully begin the
immediate process of finally bringing
our troops back home
it could at least be the beginning of
the end of the very long war here in
afghanistan signed in doha qatar was
secretary of state pompeo presiding an
agreement between the united states and
the taliban that calls for the
withdrawal of u.s troops down to about 8
600 in the next months with much of the
remainder following that the doha peace
accords
it was essentially a negotiation for our
surrender
right
the only thing that we said our
objectives were was to be able to get
out of there
um
without you know having a lot of
confrontation with the taliban but
to their credit um
they said that was conditional space in
exchange for the taliban's action
against al-qaeda and other terrorists
who could threaten us we're prepared to
begin
those force withdrawals president trump
is the one who
runs on a platform of wanting to pull
all u.s troops out of afghanistan
if you look at the afghan war today you
know it's not the afghan war as it was
you know 10 years ago back in 2010 11 we
had more than 150 000 u.s troops in
afghanistan where you know we're taking
casualties you know the afghan war
really since 2017
has been one that's been characterized
by very little u.s casualties and an a
much more competent afghan military that
has been taking the fight to the taliban
so when when president biden announced
the complete troop withdrawal on april
14th
it really registers amongst afghans as a
vote of no confidence in the afghan
government as well as the afghan army
when i came to office
i inherited a diplomatic agreement
duly negotiated between the government
and the united states and the taliban
is perhaps not what i would have
negotiated myself
but it was an agreement made by the
united states government and that means
something
incoming the current administration had
no obligation
to carry through
on that agreement it had been violated
and they chose not to carry through on a
lot of agreements in the previous
administration the idea that their hands
were tied i think is just
uh not true
and they elected to continue on with
this plan i i think it's very clear that
they did not up in their end of the deal
isis corazon was not only operating
attacked us in an area that was supposed
to be secured by the taliban
but the kakani network which is a
foreign terrorist organization is in
charge
of security in kabul
for the taliban the way i see it they
have violated every part of the
agreement i think one of the most
notable parts that's gotten a lot of
attention and deservedly so is the
release of
a whole host of high-value
taliban and al-qaeda prisoners those are
individuals who we've now seen return to
the battlefield and many of them are key
power brokers in the new taliban
government in afghanistan there's
already trouble in the u.s taliban peace
deal after seven day partial truce the
taliban now says it's resuming offensive
operations not against the u.s but
afghan forces the afghan government
rejected the deal's call for the release
of five thousand taliban prisoners we
didn't include
the afghan government
at all
uh and they were they were essentially a
non-editing when it came to this
decision
the afghans were doing 98 of the
fighting had shown a willingness to
fight
uh fight following and and many of them
had given their life process so when
when we elected to completely withdraw
regardless of the requests of the afghan
government and then withdraw the actual
military support which they relied on to
fight the taliban in many places they
were outnumbered to see is a crisis of
confidence and a complete collapse of
those institutions particularly as this
announcement is made in the lead up to
the fighting season so when that
fighting season begins we see a very
intense taliban offensive that leads to
one city and one key bit of strategic
terrain falling after another we started
seeing the taliban
essentially envelop uh provisional
capitals
without going in
and
what we saw them doing was essentially
letting everybody know
that as soon as this future all happened
that they would be
uh taking over these these towns and
there wouldn't be air support
uh hard air support to stop them
they saw that if they moved quick enough
they could get inside these urban areas
which made
air support very difficult
um before we could react and they saw
that we won't react so then we started
seeing the country falling we haven't
even withdrawn yet so the entire country
fell we see
president biden's administration orders
the evacuation of bagram air base so by
july 2nd the u.s military completes the
evacuation leaving in the middle of the
night not even alerting our afghan
allies that we were vacating
this is a decision that
only adds to the calamitous nature of
the final throne taliban takeover of
afghanistan now inevitable no the
likelihood there's going to be
the taliban overrunning everything and
owning the whole country is highly
unlikely the taliban continues to make
gains across afghanistan militants
claiming to have seized another border
crossing
on july 14th we see sven bulldog fall
on august 6th we see zoraj in nimrod's
province fall by august 8th we've seen
three more provincial capitals falls on
the taliban at this point it's obvious
to anyone watching the momentum has
shifted in their faith they had their
momentum from a military perspective and
this kept going and going and going
because they wanted it to become a fade
accomplished set that this is what's
going to happen so they can either be
the last guy who died trying to stop it
or they could just capitulate
we saw this happening it wasn't a
surprise once we saw huge areas like
kandahar the birthplace of the taliban
hurrah major city
out in the west i mean that could go
down the laundry list of significant
places that were
being taken over with some resistance
but also
a lot of just complete capitulation
simply surrendering to the taliban
allegedly depicted an amateur video
escaping to neighboring tajikistan
forces
not only leaving and this is going to be
a continuing problem leaving hundreds of
billions of dollars worth of weapons
equipment that were provided by the us
it is some of the most sophisticated in
the world
now in the hands of the call
taliban took possession of the airport
taking photographs in american military
aircraft which had been disabled
carrying the weapons that the us
government bought for the afghan army
their army went from a militia which is
the one we defeated in 2001. to now one
of the best
uh equipped militaries uh out there it's
uh it's it's a shocking
scenario that has played out in the
worst possible way back in washington
president biden briefly returned to the
white house from his camp david retreat
to address the nation about the joe
biden spent the vast majority of his
speech deflecting but he also
that president biden is playing the
blame game
blame for afghanistan's rapid fall on a
number of factors including people like
the afghan military truth is
this did unfold more quickly than we had
anticipated
so what's happened
afghanistan political leaders gave up
and fled the country
the afghan military collapsed
sometime without
trying to fight
we gave them every chance
to determine their own future
we could not provide them
it was the will to fight for that future
for those that have fought alongside him
we know that
when uh when put to the task
we have seen them fight we've seen them
not only give up their lives fighting
their television to save ours so then
the question is why why why did they
collapse
every time we try to create
a military and a very image force on our
own
it does not do well when we withdraw our
support we decided to precipitously
withdraw from iraq the isis uh menace
took on iraqi security forces
which had m1 tanks f-16 fighters um they
were adamant quite frankly and we left
in afghanistan
we saw something similar we've designed
that force to fight with a significant
airplane
they don't have a significant year
so when we stopped logging
um we left a lot of units that relied on
the president acknowledged his decision
will be criticized he said he preferred
that over passing the war to a fifth u.s
president i will not repeat the mistakes
we've made in the past
mistake of staying and fighting
indefinitely
in a conflict that is not in the
national interest of the united states
of doubling down
on a civil war in a foreign country
of attempting to remake a country
through the endless military deployments
of u.s forces this idea that endless war
is more of a political slogan it is in
our interest to stay there and ensure
stability somewhere in our american
narrative we seem to have got it in our
head that wars end when all the troops
come home and that's a prerequisite for
a war ending if you look historically
that has never been the case in fact the
troops only all come home when we lose
the war if you look at the wars that
we've won we leave troops behind to
secure the peace we still have troops
germany japan
italy spain kosovo
south korea
syria iraq somalia
5000 maybe up to 7 500 troops they could
have maintained our capability
to support uh our afghan partners
these people were not
uh going out on combat operations most
of them are supporting air operations in
support of the afghans uh ground
operations we are the united states and
we try to uphold human rights around the
world we have done i think with our
partners a great deal of good in
afghanistan the last 20 years
by the time that you know this decision
was made we had a mayor a female mayor
of kabul and i think the female
enrollment at the university was almost
matched
by the male enrolled so we had done a
lot of good but we did essentially
nothing to try to preserve that the
thing that's so remarkable is entire
afghan story
uh is that
continually the united states is
confronting crises of its own making
whether it be decisions like closing
bagram air base or withdrawal dates like
september 11th or then august 31st time
and time again afghanistan becomes a
crisis of our own creation
it was just a compilation of events that
led to this
precipitous
fall yes i would acknowledge that it was
quicker than most had thought the
intelligence community had at least one
probable scenario
where the government would fall within
weeks saying that it is probable that
the afghan government could fold on the
taliban to take over within weeks after
years withdrawal is essentially an
optimal warning that i think we should
have seen this